alors après plus de six mois d'enquête
et des dizaines d'heures d'audition nous
avons travaillé avec trois autres
rapporteurs de sensibilités différentes
sur l'industrie pornographique notamment
en France c'est un premier dans
l'histoire parlementaire jamais ce sujet
n'avait été traité ce qui a suscité
évidemment beaucoup d'engouement nous
avons travaillé sur deux axes majeurs
d'abord la protection des victimes
c'est-à-dire des victimes de violences
pornographiques oui ça existe nous avons
pu le constater l'entendre et puis deux
informations judiciaires en France sont
en cours ce qui révèle justement que
c'est une industrie opaque donc nous
avons voulu tout simplement ouvrir les
yeux sur l'industrie pornographique et
puis il y a un autre volet sur lequel je
suis particulièrement engagée c'est
l'accès aux mineurs il y a un amendement
de notre collègue Marie et Mercier qui a
été voté il y a deux ans qui n'est
malheureusement pas encore assez
appliqué c'est donc l'accès des mineurs
au site internet les sites
pornographiques à contenus
pornographiques doivent limiter
interdire l'accès aux mineurs on voit
aujourd'hui que ce n'est absolument pas
mis en place et donc nous avons souhaité
de nouveau alerter pour demander tout
simplement que la loi soit appliquée
pour quelle raison bien pour protéger
notre jeunesse deux tiers des moins de
15 ans aujourd'hui consultent
régulièrement de la pornographie un
tiers des enfants de moins de 12 ans il
y a des conséquences psychologiques
assez dramatiques pour ses enfants qui
ne vont pas uniquement ce documenter
mais aussi chercher des solutions dans
ces images pornographiques qui sont bien
loin du réel et donc c'est pour protéger
protéger aussi notre jeunesse que nous
avons souhaité faire des propositions
justement et essayer de mieux encadrer
pour limiter l'accès aux mineurs et
limiter toutes les conséquences
psychologiques qu'elles peuvent
engendrer